so you've educated
some scary number of people
so you've seen a lot of people succeed
find their
path to life is there advice that you
can give
to a young person today
about computer science education
about education in general about life
about uh whatever the
journey that one takes in there maybe in
their teens in their early twenties
instead of in those underground years as
you try to
go through the essential process of
partying and not going to classes
and yet somehow trying to get a degree
if you get to the point
where you're you're you're far enough up
in the in the
hierarchy of needs that you can actually
make decisions like this
then find the thing that you're
passionate about and pursue it
and sometimes it's the thing that drives
your life and sometimes it's secondary
and you'll do other things because
you've got to eat right
you got a family you got to feed you've
got people you have to help or whatever
i and i understand that and it's not
easy for everyone but
always take a moment or two to pursue
the things that
you love the things that bring passion
and happiness to your life and if you
don't i know that sounds corny but i
genuinely believe it
and if you don't have such a thing then
you're lying to yourself you have such a
thing you just
have to find it and it's okay if it
takes you a long time to get there
rodney dangerfield became a comedian in
his 50s
i think certainly wasn't his 20s and
lots of people failed for a very long
time before getting to where they were
going
um you know i try to have hope and it it
wasn't obvious i mean
you know we you and i talked about the
experience that i had
um a long time ago with with a
particular police officer
was it my first one it wasn't my last
one
but you know in my view i wasn't
supposed to be here after that
and i'm here so it's all gravy so you
might as well go ahead and
grab life as you can because of that
that's that's sort of how i see it
while recognizing again the delusion
matters right allow yourself to be
deluded
allow yourself to believe that it's all
going to work out just don't be so
deluded that you
you you miss the obvious uh and and
you're going to be fine
it's going to be there it's going to be
there it's going to work out
what do you think i like to say choose
your parents wisely
because that has a big impact on your
life
yeah i mean you know i mean there's a
whole lot of things that you don't get
to pick
um and and whether you get to have
you know one kind of life or a different
kind of life can depend a lot on things
out of your control
but i really do believe in the in the
passion excitement thing
my i was talking to my mom on the phone
the other day and
essentially what came out is that
computer science
is really popular right now and and and
i get to be a professor teaching
something that's very
uh attractive to people and she's she
was like
trying to give me some appreciation for
how
forsightful i was for choosing this line
of work as if somehow i knew that this
is what was going to happen in 2020
uh but that's not how it went for me at
all like i studied computer science
because i was
just interested it was just so
interesting to me i
didn't i didn't think it would be
particularly lucrative
yeah and i've done everything i can to
keep to keep it as unlucrative as
possible
yeah some of my you know some of my
friends and colleagues have
have not done that and i pride myself on
my ability to
just to remain unrich but um
but but but but i do believe that that
like i'm glad i mean i'm glad that it
worked out for me it could have been
like
oh what i was really fascinated by is
this particular kind of engraving that
nobody cares about
but um so i got lucky and the thing that
i cared about happened to be a thing
that other people
eventually cared about but i don't think
i would have had a fun time
choosing anything else like this was the
thing that kept me
interested and engaged well one thing
that people
tell me especially around the early
undergraduate
and the internet is part of the problem
here
is they say they're passionate about so
many things
how do i choose a thing which is a
harder thing
for me to know what to do with is there
any i mean don't you know
i mean you know a long time ago i
walked down the hallway and i took a
left turn yeah i could have taken a
right turn
and my world could be better or it could
be worse i have no idea i have no way of
knowing is there anything about this
particular hallway that's relevant or
you're just in general choices yeah you
were on the left
it sounds like you regret not taking the
right oh no not at all
you brought it up well because there was
a turn
there on the left was michael lemon's
office right i mean these sorts of
things happen right yes
but here's the right by the way it was
just a blank wall
it wasn't a huge choice it would have
really hurt he tried first
no but it's it's it's true right that
you know i i think about ron brockman
right i i went
i took a trip i wasn't supposed to take
and i ended up
talking to to um
on about this and i ended up going down
this entire path uh that allowed me to i
think get tenure
uh but by the way i decided to say yes
to something that didn't make any sense
and i went down this educational path
but it would have been you know who
knows right maybe if i hadn't done that
i would be a billionaire right now i'd
be elon musk my life could be so much
better
my life could also be so much worse you
know you just got to feel that sometimes
you have decisions you're going to make
you cannot know what's going to you
should think about it right some things
are clearly smarter than other things
you've got to play the odds a little bit
but in the end if you've got multiple
choices or lots of things you think you
might love go with the thing that you
actually love the thing that jumps out
at you
and sort of pursue it for a little while
the worst thing that'll happen is you
took a left turn instead of a right turn
and you ended up merely happy beautiful
so so accepting so taking the step and
just accepting
accepting that that don't like question
questions
life is long and there's time
to actually pursue every once in a while
uh you have to uh put on a leather suit
and make a thriller video every once in
a while
yeah uh i was told that you actually
danced but that part was
edited out i don't dance
there was a thing where we did do the uh
yeah the zombie thing yeah we did do the
zombies yeah
but that wasn't edited out it just
wasn't it was put into the final thing
i'm quite happy but there was a reason
for that too right like i wasn't wearing
something right there was a reason for
that i can't remember what it was no
leather suit
is that what it was i can't remember
anyway the right thing happened
exactly he took the left turn and the
third of the right end of being the
right thing
you